[Music]
only on aid a north las vegas family
grieving tonight following the murder of
a beloved husband father and son the
suspect 35 year old tristan tidwell
charged with three separate murders from
monday night but behind each victim this
man allegedly killed there are loved
ones who are suffering orc omana has the
story
well brian the family of michael myers
is still in shock right now they say he
was randomly shot and killed monday
night just minutes away from his home
while loved ones grapple with grief
they're now demanding justice
so he came to me he's like i'm going to
run down to the corner store real fast
i'll be right back those were the last
words desiree robinson ever heard from
her husband 27-year-old michael myers
desiree says michael was getting snacks
for their four kids monday night when
tragedy struck it didn't even feel real
desiree says michael was shot and killed
near cheyenne civic center the third of
three deadly shooting victims in north
las vegas on labor day the pain is real
but desiree wants to focus on michael's
life and legacy he was funny he was
caring he was always happy
always trying to just cheer someone up
the man who allegedly killed michael
tristan tidwell has a lengthy criminal
record eight news now has learned
tidwell was sentenced to six months in
jail in july for a home invasion case
but he got out early it's senseless
michael's mother nasaya tells me she
wants justice
and now we have to pick up the pieces
and deal but i need answers and i'm not
going to stop
like i need to know and he answers while
the investigation continues loved ones
want michael to be remembered he has a
whole family
a whole life like he wasn't just
some random victim you know he's
he's michael everywhere he went he made
an impact on everyone
a gofundme has been set up to help the
family during this time you can find a
link to this website on our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live tonight
orcamana 8 news now